[Music]
I've been all over his Lake for 62 years
never seen nothing like this just
happened in my lifetime well it's
certainly not our friend oh they say it
doubles in size every four to five days
and it has real long tentacles into the
water it is literally a monster that is
overtaking one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been the weevils are
the best bet because it's nature
fighting nature if it wasn't for the
whale it would be a bad trouble
[Music]
[Music]
this is giant salvinia scientists call
it the world's worst weed on the surface
it looks friendly enough it's bright
green fuzzy and it has small oval leaves
but make no mistake it is a litte killer
giant salvinia is an invasive species
from Brazil that first appeared in Texas
in 1998 under ideal conditions that can
cover 40 square miles in three months
boats can't drive through it native
plants can't grow underneath it and fish
and other wildlife struggles to survive
for 20 years we tried to get rid of it
somebody even tried to kill it with a
blowtorch once today we use an
integrated approach to manage salvinia
including a very small and unique insect
from Brazil
[Music]
by 2013 a group of us became convinced
that we will tell promised to come back
giant salvinia so we organized the
grassroots effort to build a weeble
greenhouse here in uncertain Texas the
main goal of the greenhouse is to raise
a large army of weevils with a diet of
fresh salvinia and once their numbers
expand to a certain level then we take
them out on to life I've never raised
bugs before and I'm not an entomologist
everyone here is volunteer and the
reason we're doing this is because we
care about the lake today we have raised
350,000 Weaver's this is not an easy
fight but it's worth trying to do this
they'll continue to do it I'll continue
to do it and most people down here will
continue to do what they can to save
this like
[Music]
we've had a few small areas of success I
grew up here in Pine Island Pond and
three years ago it was covered in
salvinia
but since the release of the weevils
we've seen slow but dramatic change
Caddo Lake is a unique treasure I've
fallen in it up swam in it I fished and
hunted in it this lake has been part of
my soul for almost 50 years fighting the
salvinia is not an easy task it's not
glamorous or flashy but the men and
women who fight it have no intention of
losing and at the end of the day we're
all in it for the long run huge thing
Ralph to me is the backbone of hip-hop
but it's the music that I make is
different there's no one in my lane
that's doing what I'm doing I'm bar
dealing the king and I make trailer I
rap
[Music]
trail ride is basically our culture is
basically what we love to do it's really
a lifestyle if you not hear the
witnesses then you wouldn't understand
it back in the days of people before my
grandfather used to saddle up a mule a
donkey backpacking through the woods and
they made a trail well we don't have
woods no more
so we ride up and down the streets two
by two in the line representing the
trail riding riding trucks grandmother
ride horses get on the party wagon it'd
probably be four hours probably be five
hours numbers very into the thousands we
have our own community we have our own
little world no you got your blues and
you got the zydeco
it's a Cajun style of music that come
from Louisiana that's played by a band
or accordion a rub boy
lead guitar some people use keyboards
growing up as a young kid I was always
on a horse trail riding so what I did
was I interpret all that into my music
when I started rapping there was really
no rap allowed on trail ride I came in
and I wanted to change that trying to
break the bear for young people to enjoy
trail right because I was a youngster
out there on the trail ride but you had
a hobby such as trail riding it'll pull
you away from the street I know because
it's a lot of people that trail right
that used to sell drugs that used to you
know do a lot of stuff that wasn't right
now they'd coming the trail riding and
they loved
right
[Music]
[Applause]
it means that I make it just for the
culture I represent us for the trail
riders just for those article artists
just for everything that we do country I
really feel like I had something to do
with it to change another face of terror
[Music]
we didn't really have any fast actors
from Texas until he came along like I
can't really believe my eyes
I got was in shock his hands like they
were always moving and it was like there
was no like thinking about where to put
it it was just like a non-stop just like
put it he's off the charts he's like as
fast as a lightning bolt
[Music]
my name is tre Griffith and I'm the
fastest cup sector in the state of Texas
my goal is to be the fastest cup sucker
in the whole entire world
when I first saw tre begin cups tacky I
was thrilled kids on the spectrum are
always very passionate and very intense
on what their fixation is and he just
shined I mean you could see that he was
in his element he was comfortable he was
alive and he was just doing his thing
tre took it to a completely different
level he was doing it systematically
instead of just kind of for fun and it
was all about getting that next best
time
what tre does in five or six seconds
takes me 10 or 12 13 seconds we've
learned not to ever discount what he
says he's going to do sports packing is
using a set of 12 plastic cups and you
stack them in a very specific sequence
of pyramids and you are racing yourself
and you're racing a timer it's a sport
that you don't have to be tall you don't
have to necessarily be able to run
quickly as long as you've got the 12
cups you've got Matt and you've got a
timer you can stack
to me it's just mind-boggling to see
these stackers like Trey his friends and
you can tell they're not even looking at
the cups that they're stacking it is all
muscle memory
I mean it's so fast when they get to
this level that the naked eye cannot see
it all when I found out that I was
having a boy of course I thought about
when I was a boy and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard and you flash
forward you know thinking about those
types of things with your kid out but
when Trey found stacking it's like okay
cool
here is a sport that he's into and it's
got speed I've always loved sports with
speed and it's got rhythms which make
him happy and I realized what a better
way to bond with my child than to learn
how to stock myself I get to stand next
to my son who's one of the fastest in
the world and stack with him and be a
part of something special
watching the two of them stacked
together are probably some of the best
moments I've ever had
our motto has always been the family
that stacks together stays together
and we'd go to these tournaments
together we traveled together we've made
friends all over the country all over
the world I mean it's definitely
enriched our lives
[Music]
[Music]
chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around you the drive
is taking the thermal energy from the
water unfortunately I instantaneously
get judged on my appearance that is very
frustrating for me so I'm gonna pick up
my hot water I'm gonna come over here
and I'm going to throw it right into my
bucket okay it means I have to work
harder but at the end it is so so
incredibly worth it and one my name is
dr. Katie Bergdorf and I am a lecturer
at the University of Texas at Austin I'm
trying to break the stigma of what a
stereotypical scientist looks like so my
thing is I am NOT wearing a bow tie
I'm not wearing suspenders I don't have
some frumpy cardigan on I'm just some
regular girl who likes to play with fire
I also really like designer shoes and
that's okay as the alginate hits the
calcium chloride the alginate would
prefer to be with the two plus charge
calcium instead of the one plus charge
sodium and what happens
is we form gummy worms doesn't matter
what you look like any human can be a
scientist I definitely try to use energy
and excitement for food I do my best to
try to reach students that might be
intimidated by science I use anything
that will make the 483 students sit up
straight and actually listen to the
words coming out of your mouth as soon
as I've exploded something in their face
I have their attention for just 60
seconds and I can do whatever I can to
shove that knowledge right into their
brains okay so what we're going to do
today is doing some chemistry we're
gonna do three different hands-on
experiments I find chemistry to be an
incredibly challenging topic I'm so sick
of the stereotypical female scientists
and we can do things other than biology
by the way chemistry physics engineering
we can do it the fact that I've been
able to master it but then use science
to start the conversation but then
physically stand there and break that
image it's the most rewarding thing I
could ever do ever
[Music]
this is the Texas horned lizard a
species which happens to be the official
state reptile and you know what they say
don't mess with Texas the Texas horned
lizard is aptly named because of its
numerous haunts the most prominent horns
are the two central ones located at both
the center and rear of the skull
frequently preyed upon by other animals
its distinct coloration allows it to
camouflage itself amongst vegetation but
when hunted by creatures such as snakes
coyotes and hawks
they can either inflate to a larger size
or flatten in order to blend in with the
ground however their best and more
unique defense against prey is their
ability to shoot a stream of blood from
its eyelid directly into the enemy's
eyes the Texas horned lizards population
has dropped dramatically in recent years
due to the state's rapid urbanization
leaving them with a shrinking habitat
this is the Texas horned lizard
[Music]